[Music]
we're waiting for the golden knights to
release information on tickets to their
home
game sports director chris matthews
joins us with more on the latest news on
the plan to allow some fans inside the
fortress we've been waiting chris this
is great news yeah it is great you know
ted talks about the temperatures
dropping guess what's not going to drop
the ticket prices for these games over
there yeah
hey we've been waiting all day for the
latest and at 5 30 we will actually talk
to the ticket manager
for the nights he will reveal the latest
information on acquiring tickets of the
games
now we do know this limited seating for
the march home games will go on sale
for season ticket members tomorrow
morning at 9 00 a.m
now due to limited seating knights can't
guarantee specific games locations
or number of tickets meanwhile how about
the play of marc-andre fleury that guy
is worth the price of admission
36 year old is playing terrific hockey
after last night's
third shutout this season already boy's
second of the week by the way his goals
against average
1.55 his save percentage
0.943 if you're not into hockey stats
that's
really good stuff right there flurry is
putting himself in contention for the
visna trophy given to the top goalie in
the league and to think there was a
trade involving
there was a possible trade involving
flurry this past off season but bill
foley telling us
he pushed hard to keep the flower in a
night's jersey
one day some of the guys on the hockey
staff they're going to thank me for
really being
pushing that because i was pretty
i mean i was very insistent about uh we
need
for a shortened season we need two g1
goalies
and they can alternate unfortunately
fortunately we have flower
because uh because robin's hurt you know
and he's
we'll see when he can come back he's but
he's uh he's not back yet
so i'm glad we have these two goalies
all right amazing he's back in that
vesna talk once okay fleury at some
point is gonna need some rest though
he's played seven straight games and who
knows when leonard will be back
he's still nursing that upper body
injury the knights will travel to san
jose and then anaheim this week
before returning home next monday to
face the wild
in front of fans kirsten chris you said
season ticket holders you know they get
priority what about just us
general people any chance oh you think
you get a couple tickets well the short
answer is everything has a price
there will be some tickets available on
the secondary market but again
everything does have a price vegas
already has some of the most expensive
tickets
in the entire nhl so if you got the
money i guess you can
right all right thank you chris